si vous avez du mal à gérer ce
confinement dites vous que certains ont
choisi délibérément le célèbre
spéléologue michel siffre par exemple en
1962 il passe 63 jours seul au fond d'un
gouffre le but étudier la chronobiologie
plus qu'une expérience de spéléologues
ce fut surtout un pari contre la peur
l'obscurité la faim et le froid au bout
de deux mois et après avoir survécu à un
éboulement
il remonte enfin à la surface je
récupère hopper je ne compare pas percé
après quoi la peur la peur je commence à
être saturé la peur maintenant
maintenant je vais me calmer un peu
quelqu'un que quelques mois
son expérience va intéresser la nasa car
cette absence de lumière et de repères
temporels sont les mêmes que pour les
astronautes
autre expérience en 1984 en pleine
guerre froide
quatre personnes vont vivre lui jours
dans un abri anti atomique
le but étudier les interactions sociales
dans ce milieu hostile
l'ingénieur qui a conçu la bri faisait
partie des quatre participants qui
pouvaient ainsi constaté ces défauts au
niveau de waters revoir un petit peu
une quantité parce qu'on est fait quand
même juste fait faire très très
attention et les odeurs vous en page est
née elle doit il ya eu d'autres
expériences de confinement à des fins
scientifiques
les astronautes peut par exemple se
prépare au voyage sur mars en étant
enfermés 520 jours
mais il ya aussi des confinement
volontaire juste pour le plaisir à la
frontière hollandaise on a fait la queue
pendant 120 jours pour entrevoir
moyennant 40 ans belge d'un franc pour
les enfants louis le parc s'enfuit dans
un cercueil à deux mètres sous terre et
communiquant avec le monde par la
lucarne d'une étroite chemine
enfin un petit conseil pour gérer
l'enfermement s'est offert par un sous
marinier legault comme on voit dans les
films le mec il coche les jours il y en
a qui font ça non c'est pas ça
moi j'ai compté les jours à partir du
moment où on est passé dans le bon sens
des rebonds je savais qu'on partait donc
fait pour un mois dès qu'on a eus fait
quinze jours après que c'est passé à 14
là j'ai commencé à compter mais je dois
dire que d'ailleurs c'était une erreur
puisque les trois derniers jours c'est
vrai c'est horrible parce qu'il ya la
tension la joie de rentrée c'est long
c'est aller on tient bon et on reste à
la maison
[Musique]